[Music]
the Brookstone company you all know them
they filed for bankruptcy protections
it's a big story yeah we all know Brooke
stones well they filed for bankruptcy
and you know we know the Brookstone
catalog we know all their mall stores so
the bankruptcy news was kind of a
surprise I didn't see this one coming
that's why I invited Don Kenworth the
CEO of Brookstone to explain just how it
happened we have in the satellite hookup
are you how are you done give me okay
all right here : good good you can hear
me okay how did Brookstone get to this
point frankly kkona we have no idea
at Brookstone we made innovative
products that Americans couldn't live
without like this garden trowel that's
also a karaoke mic how's everybody doing
in it all right
see actually that might be a problem I
think we can live life without that
thing well how about this oven mitt with
Wi-Fi okay why would anyone need an oven
mitt with Wi-Fi well it's the fastest
way to download your music into your
salad bowl mp3 player okay the shape of
the bowl acts as a natural speaker okay
yeah okay amazing but what if you put a
salad in it well then it's very muffled
and you'd void the warranty okay look
that's the problem and see all
Brookstone did was add technology to
things that people already have and then
they would jack up the price that's the
problem
ouch but true that's why last week we
filed for bankruptcy and I'm gonna
commit honorable suicide with this
beautiful titanium golf tee and cyanide
injector okay
please sir that's no reason to kill
yourself too late now
[Music]
wait a minute this is he dead or just
frozen I guess that make any sense
saying I just paralyzed yeah I guess it
paralyzes you standing up when you die
is that what happens I didn't think
about that from beyond the grave and
beyond the grave still a little bit of
life there that's one we didn't think
through it rehearsal yeah his name is
the character's name is dawn Kenworth
everybody how you doing over there
[Applause]